Let's add 249 to 383.
Now, the first thing you want
to do with any type of
addition problem, especially
when you have multiple digits,
is to write the two numbers
above and below each other.
So we have 200-- let me write
a little bigger than that--
249 plus 383.
And you want to line them up
so that we have the same
places above and below
each other.
So the 9 and the 3 are both in
the ones place here, so we've
lined them up.
The 4 and the 8 are both in the
tens place, and the 2 and
the 3 are both in the
hundreds place.
If you had a thousands place in
one of them and not in the
other, it would just kind of
be sitting out here by
themselves.
The easiest thing is just to
kind of both make them line up
to the right, or the
ones places.
Now I'll show you the process,
but while we do the process,
we'll think a little bit about
why it makes sense.
So we start at the ones place,
and we say what is 9 plus 3?
So we say 9 plus 3.
Well, that's equal to 12.
I'm writing the 1 in 12 in
orange on purpose, because
when you want to write the sum
down here, you can't write a
two-digit number.
You can only write a digit
between 0 and 9.
So what we do is 9 plus
3 is 12, that's the
equivalent of 10 plus 2.
So we write the 2 in the ones
place, and the 1, which is
really representing 10, we put
in the tens place, which
hopefully makes sense.
This now represents 10.
And now we want to add this
10 plus 40 plus 80.
It looks like we're adding a 1
to a 4 to an 8, but these are
really in the tens place,
so this is really a
10, a 40 and an 80.
But if you just think about
the process, you just take
your 1, you add it to your 4 and
your 8-- plus 4 plus 8--
and what do you get?
1 plus 4 plus 8 is what?
5 plus 8, that is 13.
I'll write it like this.
Actually, this is in the tens
place, so it actually
represents 130, but you don't
have to think about that.
The process is fairly
straightforward.
You have 13.
You write the 3 down here, and
we regroup the 1 or, you might
have learned, you carry
the 1, so then you
carry the 1 up here.
Same process now in the
hundreds place.
This 1 actually represent a
hundred, because this was
actually 130 because it
was in the tens place.
So we have a 1 plus 2 plus
3, what is that?
Well, that's just 6, right?
1 plus 2 is 3 plus 3 is 6.
So that is equal to 6.
So we write it right
over here.
So 249 plus 383 is 632.